غالبا ما تبدا الحياه الزوجيه بشكل سعيد
للغايه لكن بعد مرور الوقت وتطور العلاقه
قد يتغير الامر ويدخل الفتور لدينا اليوم
دراستين مفادهما بان من اسرار النجاح في
الزواج الابتعاد والدراسه الثانيه مفادها
لان السعاده الزوجيه اساس لصحه القلب
الخبراء ومستشارون علاقات الاسريه كشفوا
عن اسباب المشاكل ومنها ان الزوج المحب
للمكوس في البيت وراء فتور العلاقه بين
الشركين فالخبراء يشيرون الى ان الزوجين
اللذين يعتدان على برنامج روتيني ارتداء
فيها بالنوم وشاهده الفاعل السنه والطعام
معا يصبح وجودهما معا نقما في البيت لان
الروتين يقتل المشاعر التي من شانها ان
تحرك الافكار وتنمل المهارات الذهنيه
سالنا الناس في الاردن سر السعاده الزوجيه
في البعد ما رايكم
[موسيقى]
بصير معي
اكثر
والعلاقه بتقرا
بالعلاقه
يعني بتملي بتزهقي وهو بميل
[موسيقى]
انا مع هاي الدراسه ومع هذه الابحاث لانه
عن تجربه بحكي انه مرات انا ممكن بسافر
لحالي هيك فتره عن زوجي وحتى هو لما يغيب
حتى لما يغيب بالشغل انا بكون يعني مشاعري
وهو مثلا بعيد عني بحس باشتياق
وبيعمل سعاده اكثر من يظله بوجهه بعد اكيد
يعني
نعم انا باكد على هذا الحكي عن تجربه بحكي
لك ههه
[موسيقى]
فكره كلها غلط
الزوجين مع بعض ودائما يكونوا مع بعض
الحياه
اصلا الحياه
البعد جفى
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان السعاده الزوجيه مهمه و ضروريه
اكثر مما كنا نتخيل فالامر تجاوز الصحه
النفسيه ووصل الى صحه الجسم وتحديدا القلب
وبحسب صحيفه الديلمي البريطانيه فانا
مشكلات العلاقات الزوجيه يمكن ان تؤدي الى
اجهاد شديد ما يؤثر سلبا في صحه القلب
والاصابه بالم في الصدر وواجزع علماء
بجامعه لصحه العامه عن الازواج غير
السعداء في علاقاتهم هم اكثر عرضه بنسبه
50% ادخلهم الى المستشفى بعد اصابته بنوبه
واشار الى انهم كانوا اكثر عرضه بالنسبه
لسبعه 67% للابلاغ عن الام بالصدر في
العام الذي اعجبنا بعض النتائج اظهرت ان
الحياه الشخصيه يمكن ان تؤدي دورا
الرئيسيين في ساعات الناس والاجهاد الذي
يعانيه المرء في الحياه اليوميه مثل
الاجهاد الزوجي قد يؤثر في ساعات الشباب
بعد نوبه
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى جده واستشاريه ارشاد نفسي واسري
الدكتوره هوازن بن زقر اهلا بك دكتور
هوازن يعني من الهد لاين انا متاكده انه
الازواج مركزين معنا بدهم يعرفوا يوصلوا
لهذه المقابله معاك عشان نعرف اكثر بهذا
الموضوع اليوم هل فعلا سر في السعاده
الزوجيه هو البعد ولا البعيد عن القلب
بعيد عن العين بعيد عن القلب زي ما
بيقولوا
اهلا وسهلا فيك حبيبتي شوفي بالنسبه الي
دائما ما في قاعده عامه لانه كمان يعتمد
على الاطراف المتزوجين انه انت ايش بالضبط
تحتاج من هذا الزواج لكن حقيقي للدراسات
الحديثه اثبتت انه الحياه الي فيها نيجي
نقول احصاه وليس منفصله يعني ما نقول
الحياه المنفصله هيك يعني بتنجح الزواج
ويكون اكثر سعاده قد ما نقول انه الحياه
الخاصه انه الكل طرف فيه الزواج سواء تزوج
او الزوجه عندما الحياه الخاصه اللي هي
نقدر نقول السويس لانه هذه المساحه تخلي
الانسان عنده حريه اكثر عنده اشباح رغبات
زي مثلا نقول
هتخرج مع صاحباتها في حقتك ذاتها مهنيه
علميه قراءتها جروباتها الناس اللي تمضي
وقت حتى كمان ما يصير فيه تصادم والكونفلك
والتعارض بين الزوجات
رهام فالحياه الخاصه حقيقيه
يعني من مقومات الزواج السعيد
مما لا شك فيه ان العلاقه الاسريه العلاقه
الزوجيه بالتحديد علاقه معقده يعني وتحتاج
كثير من التفسير ولا قاعده لها لكن
بالغالب الانسان يختار شريك حياته الذي
يحبه ويصعد ويريد ان يعيش معه لحظات جميله
لماذا في اغلب الاحيان تتحول هذه النعمه
الى نقمه
[موسيقى]
شوفي في عدم توافق فكري وفي احيانا على
فكره يكون في اضطرابات نفسيه لازم الطرف
من الازواج او الطرفين بس هو ما هم على
وعد فيهم غير من اهم النقاط اللي لازم
نعرفها حتى لو الناس مثلا لما يجوا يقولوا
الطرفين ما عندها اي طلبات طبيعي لما
اقابل احد يكون مثلا سيف نايف بالنسبه لي
فانا ضامنه فطلع غضبي في همم انا كنت
متوتر من امور ماديه من امور ثانيه فاطلع
مثلا ولكن مره ننصح اكثر حاجه لما يكون في
وسط يعني تواصل وسائل التواصل جيده بين
الطرفين يعني زي ما قبل شويه منفصله
والحياه اللي فيها خصوصيه كثير ناس يقلب
ومره يخافوا ويحسوا احد من قابل يكون فيه
ليش لانه داخليا ممكن يكون عنده خوف وعدم
امان في هذا الزواج بيحس انه لا ما ابغى
الشخص يسيبك ممكن يكون في عندنا مشاكل
تعلق لانه كمان لما انا اكون دائما مع
الشخص معتمد فيه عندي مشكله تعلق فهذا هو
في الانسان لما يحس انا اعتمد على نفسي
ومستقيل بتاعك ولكن كان الشخص ده جنبي
يشاركني هذه الاشياء اللي انا احبها في
حياتي هذا مهم
لانه انا يعني بسمع عن بس ما عن زوجات
بيحبوا ازواجهم بس يسافروا مثلا شو رايك
هي مو تحبه
تكتشف ان هي تحبه وتبدا تستوعب انه هو
جنبها
او متطلب منها تعمل اشياء كثير او ممكن
ينتقدها او حتى الجلوس ممكن بس لما بيروح
بتفتكر الاشياء الكويسه تفتكر اشياء هي مش
شايفه هي الناس
اللي احنا عايشين فيها اساسا للاسف احيانا
اياها زي مثلا
ما بتحسي فيها لانك انت كل يوم الحمد لله
موجوده
على فكره الزواج هو عنده مميزات وعنده
ايجابيات بس انا ما حط فيها غير لما هو
موجود لانه هو لما يكون موجود انا ضامنا
هذه النعامه وبالتالي ابدا انا ادور على
الكمال ادور على مشاكل طيب انت ليش ما
بتعمل كده او انت غير مسؤول بهذا الشغل
ومن هنا من هذه النقطه يعني هي مو ما تحبه
ابدا هي تحبه بس تشوف نعم
كانه من الواضح فعلا هذه قصه البعد مثبت
علميا لانه مثلا فتره كرهنا الناس كانت
ماشيه على روتين قبل من شغله من شغلات
الحياه قعدوا مع بعض فترات طويله زادت
حالات الطلاق وزادت المشاكل والعنف
بالضبط مهندسه صحيح لانه في هنا قلت لك ما
في متنفس يخرجه
ضغوطات الحياه ولا حتى احتياجاتهم مو بس
يحتاج العيله الصحه عن الصلاه يحتاج اشياء
جوانب اخرى
في الحياه طبعا هذا كمان شكل ضغط كويس
من اكثر العوامل هي هذه هي التعرض الدائمه
وكمان الخوف الشديد والنفسيه اللي يمر
فيها الناس سهله لانه كمان تغير الحال همم
الخوف من المستقبل الخوف من المجهول سببت
قلق لدرجه انه مو شرطه
طبيعي
شكرا لك من جده
استشاريه استشهاد نفسي دكتوره هوازن بين
ذكر شكرا